[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN MALCOLMSON: Thank you.
Thanks, Phil.
Thank you all so much
for being here today.
I know this is precious
time for everyone.
So I really cherish this
opportunity to be with you all.
I'm excited to share a
story with you guys today
that's hopefully going to
inspire you, and encourage
you, and really leave
you in awe that you
do have an amazing purpose
wherever you're at,
that you have an incredible
purpose right where you're at.
And so I'm going to
share this story.
And there's something
unique about a story.
When someone says that there's
a story out there for you,
it kind of resonates with
you in a different way
than when you hear truth,
or facts, or a date,
or something like that.
When you hear a story,
stories stick with you
in a very unique way.
And so this story, I hope,
will kind of echo in your heart
as you leave from here today.
And make you think
and really consider
that you truly do have
an incredible purpose
right where you're at.
I'm going to take
you back a few years.
I was a student at USC,
University of Southern
California down in Los Angeles.
Don't worry, my parents
didn't help me get in.
My parents aren't celebrities.
So I think I got
in on my own merit.
But I was a student there
just trying to find my way
and trying to figure out what
I was going to do in my career
after I graduated, and I
stumbled into journalism.
I wanted to be a sportswriter
and write about sports.
I had loved watching
ESPN as a kid
and reading the sports section
of the newspaper and "Sports
Illustrated."
So I figured, why don't I
go be a sports reporter?
Kind of combine my
passions and do something
I'm really excited about.
So my first assignment in
being a journalism major
was to write for the school
newspaper, "The Daily Trojan."
And so I go to
"The Daily Trojan",
and they assigned me to
cover women's volleyball
my first assignment.
I had never seen a women's
volleyball match in my life,
so here I am on Wikipedia trying
to learn the scoring system.
And I mean, I was struggling.
I was really fighting to keep
my head above water here.
It was a fish out
of water totally.
And a couple weeks into
this volleyball assignment
for the school newspaper
the editor says,
hey, we have an opening
on the football beat.
Would you like to cover
the football team?
Before he could even
finish asking the question
I was like, yes, count me in.
Let's go.
Because I actually
knew what football was.
I had actually watched a
football game before in my life
and actually knew how to
keep track of football
scores and all that.
So here I am.
I go and start covering
the football team at USC.
And this is right at
the start of their run.
For the next three
years they went
to three straight national
championship games.
They won 34 consecutive games.
They went on this unprecedented
run in college football
in the mid 2000s.
And I got to cover the
team for those three years.
I got to go to all three of
those national championship
games.
I got to go to two
Heisman Trophy ceremonies.
I got to go to every single
home and away football game
as my job in college.
Now, many of you who
went to college you
had some pretty crazy
jobs in college.
A lot of my friends had
some pretty funky jobs,
like janitor in the middle
of the night in the dorms,
or working in the IT department
in the middle of the night,
keeping stuff running.
I got to have an
incredible job of covering
a football team, the number
one team in the country.
Every home and away game,
travel, all that stuff.
And this was what
I was getting paid
to do as a college student.
I was living a dream.
This was unbelievable.
And so I was gearing up to
graduate three years later,
and I lived this
amazing journey.
And I wanted to write one final
good story about the football
team before I left.
And so I'm searching
around, digging around,
trying to find one final
good story for this student
newspaper.
And I see a little alert
that comes up that says,
walk-on tryouts for the
football team are coming up.
And so walk-ons are the
end of the bench guys.
They don't get scholarships
to play in college,
so they're paying their
own way to be there.
They don't get newspaper
articles written about them.
They're never on "SportsCenter."
They're kind of the
unheralded guys.
And so I was like,
why don't I write
an article about these guys?
Do something that hadn't
really been done before.
And so I start
interviewing some guys that
can go through this
tryout, and it's
kind of an open casting call.
Any student at USC can
try out for the team.
And so here I am
interviewing some guys
that are going to go through
this, and in this process
it hits me.
Well, why don't I go
through the tryout myself?
Really bring people
on the inside.
Show people a
first-person perspective
how hard this is to go through
the tryout for the number one
college football
team in the country.
Now before I go any further, I
do have to be honest with you
guys.
Not only, as I mentioned, was
I a student newspaper reporter,
I was really skinny.
I was 165 pounds.
But on top of
that, the last time
I played football
was in fifth grade.
So it had been more than 10
years since I played football,
and here I was going through
the tryout for the number one
college football
team in the country.
So this was going
to be a total joke.
I mean, here I was,
student newspaper reporter
going through the tryout for
the best team in the country,
having not played football
since fifth grade.
I could go through this
tryout, show how hard it is,
and really just
make fun of myself.
It would just be a total
joke of an article.
So I go through the tryout,
and I'm really just soaking it
all up.
This was going to be
the story of a lifetime.
I get home that night, and
I mean, I hit a goldmine.
This was the coolest story
I could have ever imagined.
I got to try out for
this football team.
There's Pete Carroll, who is
head coach of USC at the time,
yelling at me during
in the tryout.
I'm running 40-yard dash for
the first time in my life.
I mean, this was so
cool, and I'm bringing
all the readers on the inside.
This is such an
amazing opportunity.
And so I go home.
I start writing my
story, and I was so
excited to put this together.
And the next morning I get
a phone call saying, hey,
is this Ben Malcolmson?
And I was like,
yeah, this is Ben.
And the lady on the
other end of the line
goes, well, you made
the football team.
Now, I laughed at first, too,
because this had to be a joke.
There's no way.
There were 40 guys
at the tryout.
39 of them were trying
their hearts out
to make this football team.
There was one guy there, me,
not trying to make the team.
I had no intention of
ever making this team
because my sole
intention in being there
was to write a
really cool article.
And I achieved
that at this point.
I was happy.
So I get this phone call,
and I'm just in shock.
I laugh at the lady, and she's
like, no, no, no, I'm serious.
You're on the team.
And I'm like, there's no way.
This can't be true.
She's like, your
name's on the list.
You've got to come
in and check in.
So I hop on my bike.
I start pedaling as fast as
I can over to the football
building just to make
sure this is legit
and actually check into
this football team.
And I walk up to the
football building,
and it hits me there in that
moment that Coach Carroll--
he was the head coach
of USC at the time.
He's renowned for
pulling pranks.
You can go on YouTube right now
and type in Pete Carroll prank.
I mean, don't do it right
now, because we're talking.
But after this type in Pete
Carroll prank on YouTube,
and you'll get a dozen
pranks that'll show up.
He's a kid at heart.
He's a jokester.
So it hits me that I'm going to
be the butt end of his latest
prank.
I mean, what better target
than the 21-year-old student
newspaper reporter who had
just gone through a tryout?
Of course I'm going to be the
butt end of his latest prank.
So now here I am,
talking myself into, OK,
I'm about to get the rug
pulled out from under me.
I'm going to walk out
to the football office.
There's going to be Pete
Carroll, Will Ferrell,
and Snoop Dogg, and they're
all going to point laugh at me.
And here I am.
Oh man, I'm fully ready
for this to happen.
I walk up to the office,
the football office there,
and there's Pete Carroll.
Big old grin on his face,
and he's like, hey, Ben.
And I was like, hey
coach, joke's over.
Nice one, nice prank.
And he's like, no,
no, no, I'm serious.
You can catch the ball.
You can run fast.
We want you on the team.
Are you in?
There in that moment,
I was like, OK,
maybe this isn't a joke.
Maybe this is serious,
but here, this
is the best college football
coach at the time telling me,
who hadn't played
football in 10 years,
that I could maybe
play football.
This is crazy.
And he's like, are you in?
And I was like, of
course I'm in, let's go.
So there in that moment, I go
from a student's paper reporter
to all of a sudden being a
wide receiver on the number one
college football
team in the country.
This is crazy.
I could have never dreamed
of something like this.
So here in this moment my
life takes a total turn.
And they go and
hand me a playbook.
And I've played video games,
Madden football and stuff
like that, but this playbook
was nothing like that at all.
This playbook was like
learning a new language.
I go get handed my
helmet and my pads.
I didn't know which was
front and back on my pads.
I was so embarrassed.
This is the biggest joke.
I'm just losing myself here.
I don't know what was going on.
So then I'm out at practice.
I'm getting my head beat.
I'm getting crushed.
I'm like a tackling
dummy out there.
I'm like fresh meat
for these guys.
Here I am, a small little
kid out there basically,
and hadn't played
football in 10 years,
and I'm just getting
leveled left and right.
I'm starting to
get the hang of it.
It took a couple weeks.
I was starting to
gain some weight.
I went to Taco Bell
a lot late at night.
Started to gain some
weight and was lifting
a lot of weight and all that.
And starting to
learn the playbook,
and I'm starting to actually
feel and look a little bit more
like a football player, little
by little, day after day.
About a month into
spring practice
I'm out blocking on
a play, and I get
my arm caught in a guy's pad.
And we roll over in
this freak injury.
I'm lying there on the field.
My shoulder's dislocated.
And the doctors rush out.
They sent me to the hospital
there on campus, and they say,
you need emergency
reconstructive surgery
on your shoulder because your
shoulder is just destroyed.
So there in the
span of a month I
go from a student
newspaper reporter,
who had been typing, to all of
a sudden being on the football
field, getting beaten
left and right.
And now here I am.
I have to get emergency
reconstructive
surgery on my shoulder.
So my dream that I'd
started to live into
and started to take hold
of, this newfound, new life,
that I had, this new dream
that was all exciting,
it all of a sudden gets
ripped from my hands.
I was crushed.
I was so discouraged
and devastated.
And maybe you've
been in a situation
like that, too, where
you feel like, man, I'm
onto something here.
I'm onto something really
cool and really exciting.
And then all of a sudden
it gets taken from you.
So I just decided I
was going devote myself
to the rehab process.
The doctor said I was going
to be out for nine months,
but maybe I could
get back quicker.
Maybe I could get back
just a little bit faster
than nine months.
I just poured myself
into this rehab process
and just tried to get
back a little bit faster.
Four and a half months later I'm
with the doctors, and they say,
we can't believe
this is happening,
but you're actually
100% healthy.
You're able to return
to the football field.
Half the time the
doctor said, there
I was all of a sudden
back to practicing.
This was a miracle.
There's no way this could have
happened other than it was just
a miracle healing.
I was so amazed.
So there I am back to
practicing that fall,
suiting up for practice.
And then for home games I get
to dress out in the uniform
and run out of the tunnel at
the LA Coliseum, 92,000 people.
This was incredible.
It was just literally
living a dream.
And I was content
just doing that.
But I was alone in that
thought because there
was a group of
students that wanted
to see me get into a game.
So they started a campaign
called Get Ben In.
And they wanted to see just
the guy who represented
the average student.
Not the huge muscled
up football player,
but just the normal student get
into a game for this number one
team.
And so they started
this campaign.
They made T-shirts.
They made posters.
They started chants in the
student section, Get Ben In.
And we make it for the
last home game of the year.
I hadn't played yet.
And it's number six Notre
Dame versus number three
USC at the LA Colosseum,
92,000 people.
So that story, in and of itself,
we could walk out of here
and be like, oh wow, that
was really cool story.
That's really cute, and
I'm kind of inspired.
It was a unique
little football story.
But the best part
about that story
is what God was doing
behind the scenes.
What I mentioned
at the beginning,
that this sense of
purpose that we all have,
and when I made that team I had
this deep, overwhelming sense
that God had put me on
that team for a reason.
That I was there for a purpose.
And so I was pressed
into that from day one.
And I couldn't wait to see
why I was on that team.
Because if there needed
to be another football
player on that team,
there were a lot
of other stronger, faster,
bigger guys than me.
But I was picked
for that team, and I
felt like I had a divine
reason on that team.
So I was pressing into it.
I couldn't wait to see
why I was on that team.
And a month or so
into being on the team
I get this nudge on my heart
that I need to start a Bible
study for the team.
Like many of you in
here are probably
involved in some kind of
fellowship here at Google,
and someone at some point felt
this nudge to start it here.
And that's the nudge I felt.
And I was like, OK,
there's no Bible study.
I'm going to start
this Bible study.
And made flyers, passed them
out to all my teammates.
Told all the guys on the
team and got a Bible study
lesson ready.
And the room got ready, and
time comes for our first Bible
study, and I'm sitting
there all alone.
No one showed up.
So I'm discouraged.
I'm defeated.
I'm sitting here questioning,
why am I on this team?
What is my purpose
in being here?
Because if I had a
purpose then you'd
think at least one other
person would show up.
So then I'm wrestling with this
discouragement and this doubt.
And about a month or so later I
get another nudge in my heart.
Let me start a prayer
group for the team.
We'll gather together.
We'll pray together as a bunch
of believers on the team,
and the time will come,
and it'll be awesome.
We'll pray together.
We'll encourage one another,
and this'll be great.
So I made flyers.
I passed them out
to all my teammates.
Got a room ready, and the time
comes for our first prayer
meeting as a team, and you
guessed it, no one showed up.
So now here I am, twice as
defeated, twice as discouraged,
and questioning my
purpose even more.
Why am I here?
Why am I on this team?
And maybe you
resonate with that.
Maybe you're wrestling with
something like that right
now in your workplace, at home
with some friends that you
have.
Maybe you're wrestling with
this discouragement of, man,
I feel like I have a
purpose, but sometimes
I just don't see it.
I was in that spot,
and it's hard.
As many of you, if not most
of you, if not all of you,
can relate with,
it's really hard.
So I'm wrestling with
this discouragement,
and it takes me a little
while to get through that,
and a month or two later, I
get another idea in my heart.
I just read in the book
of Matthew Chapter 5,
and it says, "let your
light shine before men."
And it hits me in that moment
that lights just shine.
Before they go create
events, before they
go do anything, lights
first and foremost,
just shine where they're at.
And so I just needed
to be a light.
I was so focused on creating
something, doing something,
that I lost track of
the fact that I just
needed to be a light.
Just be a positive, uplifting,
loving person to the people
around me.
So I devoted myself to that.
I'm going to be a light.
This is going to be awesome.
And now I'm going to see the
fruit of my labor in this way.
So I pour myself into this, and
weeks and weeks, maybe a month
or two go by, and once again,
I'm not seeing any results.
Once again, I'm discouraged,
defeated, and questioning what
is my purpose on this team.
Because if I had a purpose,
you'd think I would see it.
And I'm just not seeing it.
So at this point we're
almost at the end of season.
We get chosen to play
in the Rose Bowl, which
is on New Year's Day.
And a few weeks
before the Rose Bowl I
was reading in the book
of Isaiah, Chapter 55.
It says, "if His word goes
out, it will not return empty."
And so I knew that God is
always faithful to His promise.
I knew that He is
always true to His word,
and that if I put
His word out there,
if I put His literal word out
there it will not return empty.
And so I got this idea--
I'm going to get a Bible for
every one of my teammates.
I'm going to pass one out to
every one of my teammates,
and God's going to be
faithful to His word.
That if I put his
word out there it's
not going to return empty,
that it will achieve a purpose.
So I was so excited.
I called my grandfather.
He works for this organization
called the Gideons.
They're the ones that pass
out free Bibles in hotels,
and you open up the
drawer in the hotel room,
and there's a Gideon
Bible right there.
And so I called him
up, shared my idea,
and I was like,
what do you think?
He's like, I'll
send you 100 bibles.
So a week or two
later, I get 100 bibles
delivered to my doorstep.
And I wanted to make it kind
of an anonymous Christmas gift.
It was right before
Christmas, and I
figured I was tired of being the
guy that was out there trying
to make an impact, trying
to find my purpose,
and everything failing.
So this one I'm going to do
completely under the radar.
I'm going to be totally
anonymous on this one.
And so I typed up a
little red note that said,
a Christmas gift for you.
The greatest present you will
ever receive, Jesus Christ.
Merry Christmas.
And I stuck one of these
red notes in every Bible,
and at 11 o'clock at
night on Christmas Eve
I went into the locker
room, and I placed one Bible
in every locker.
I didn't want anyone to know
that it was me doing this,
so I waited till it was
late at night as possible.
I didn't even want
the janitor to know
that it was me doing this.
And so I'm placing one in every
locker, and in this process
I had this overwhelming sense
that this was my purpose.
Sure, I thought the prayer
group was my purpose.
Sure, I thought the Bible
study was my purpose.
Sure, I thought trying to
be a light was my purpose.
But all those things
had failed, and this
is why I was there, placing
a Bible in every one
of my teammates' locker.
So we had Christmas Day
off, and we get back
on the 26th of December for our
first day back of our last week
together before the
game on January 1,
our last game of the season.
I was senior.
This was my last chance.
And so I knew that this was my
purpose of being on this team.
I was running out of time.
This had to be it.
And so I'm walking over
to the football building
that morning on the 26th, fully
expecting just the greatest
of things to happen.
I was a zealous 21-year-old.
I was so excited to see what God
was going to do through this.
And I'm walking
up just expecting,
like, the Hallelujah chorus to
be sung from the locker room,
gold light to be emanating
from the locker room doors.
I was fully expecting just the
craziest of things to happen.
And I pulled the door
to the locker room,
and I pull it open.
There were Bibles just
thrown all over the floor,
shredded everywhere.
All you could see were just
shredded pages of Bible
all over the floor.
You couldn't even
see the carpet.
I was absolutely crushed.
My discouragement
went to a new low.
I was completely devastated.
Here I tried to find my purpose
through the Bible study,
through the prayer group,
through being a light, now
through these Bibles,
and I had failed.
Not just again, but I had
failed miserably this time.
So you can imagine
my disappointment,
my discouragement.
We go through that week
leading up to the Rose Bowl,
and I just had this
hole in my heart
that I had missed my purpose
of being on that team.
We play in the Rose Bowl.
I go home after
the game, and I get
a phone call a few days after
the game saying, hey, did you
about Mario?
Now, Mario was our kicker on
the team, record-setting kicker.
He just finished
his junior year.
He had one more year
left in college.
And I was like, no,
what happened to Mario?
And my friend, my teammate
on the other end of the line
goes, oh no, you didn't hear.
Mario died last night.
21 years old, he
had mysteriously
passed away just a few days
after our last game together.
So now not only was I dealing
with this discouragement
of trying and failing
to find my purpose,
but now I'm dealing
with this grief.
At 21 years old, losing a
friend, one of my closest
friends, one of my teammates.
Same age as me, 21.
This is heartbreaking.
I didn't even know
how to fathom it.
how to process this.
We go to this funeral as
a team a few days later,
and I'm sitting
right on the aisle,
and they carry his casket
down the center aisle.
And I look up right as
the casket passes by.
And on top of the
casket was this Bible
with a red note sticking out of
it, just resting right on top
of the casket.
And I had no idea what
it meant at the time,
but it just felt like it was
God's personal comforting touch
for me.
Just to say like, I see
you, I saw you all along.
And it gave me immense comfort.
It was just such an
incredible moment
that I had with
God in that moment.
So then a few months
later after working
through that grief
and all that stuff,
I ended up starting to work
at USC for Coach Pete Carroll
there.
He was the head
coach at the time.
And three years
later, he took the job
with the Seattle
Seahawks in 2010.
Asked me to follow
him up here, and I'd
moved up not knowing anyone.
And for those of
you that have moved,
either for jobs or
whatnot, and you move
and you don't know anyone
there, and it's so hard.
It's so challenging.
And how do you make friends?
It's just, like, the most
challenging thing ever.
So I was desperate
to make friends.
I'd say hi to someone
in the grocery store,
and I was like, oh, maybe
they'll be my friend.
Maybe the person behind
me in Starbucks, maybe
they'll buy my coffee.
Maybe we can have a
conversation today.
I was just so desperate,
so lonely to make friends.
So I come across this one guy
who's a really outgoing guy,
and he starts telling me about
this group called Young Life.
Young Life is a high
school mentorship program.
It's got a big footprint
here in the Seattle area.
And he starts
telling me about this
and that they need
volunteer leaders.
I was like, whatever it is,
I'm in because I need something
to do with my time.
So I show up at this Young Life
informational leader meeting,
and I'm just trying
to learn what
this whole organization is.
And as I'm sitting there
a former teammate of mine
walks through the door.
His name was Taylor.
He was our punter on the team.
Now, I hadn't seen
him in four years.
The last time I saw him
was at Mario's funeral,
four years earlier,
1,000 miles from where
we were at this point.
And we're outside Seattle.
This is crazy.
What are we both
doing in this spot?
So we remove ourselves
from this meeting.
We're catching up, and he's
like, dude, my life has totally
turned around the
last few years.
I was like, well, what happened?
He's like, do remember the
last week we were on the team
together there were Bibles
in all of our lockers?
Now, I hadn't thought about
these Bibles in years.
Because these Bibles with the
red notes sticking out of it,
they symbolized discouragement.
They symbolized defeat.
And ultimately, they symbolized
the death of a friend
and a teammate of mine.
So when he said that my initial
reaction was just play dumb.
So I go, yeah, I don't know.
I kind of remember those.
I don't really know.
What about those Bibles?
And so he starts to tell me that
he grew up in a Christian home.
He grew up going to church.
When he went to
college he decided
to leave the faith and kind
of live life on his own terms
and do things the way
he wanted to do it.
And so he's going about
his daily life in college,
and for four years
does his own thing.
So when he sees a Bible in
his locker that morning,
his last week on the team,
he's kind of confused,
and he's also a little annoyed.
Like, what is this
Bible doing here?
I don't really need
this right now.
He throws it in the
back of his locker.
He's going to go out to the
practice field that day,
and he's thinking he's the last
one to leave the locker room.
And he's pushing the door
to go out to the field,
and he hears a voice in the
back corner of the locker
room going, what is this?
And so he was confused
because he thought
he was the last one in there.
And he turns around, and
there's Mario our kicker,
sitting in his locker, thumbing
through the Bible, going,
what is this?
And so Taylor tells me
that he turns around,
and he screams across
the locker room, Mario,
have you never seen
a Bible before?
Mario is like, what am I
supposed to do with this thing.
Taylor and Mario-- they
were best of friends.
They were the punter
and the kicker.
They spent all
their time together.
And so Taylor for some
reason sets down his helmet
and his pads there
at the doorstep,
turns around, walks back,
and sits down next to Mario.
And for 45 minutes takes
him through the Bible.
Every word in red are the
words of Jesus Christ,
the Son of God, the
Savior of the world,
the one who came to die,
to take on your sins,
to make you right with God.
They missed half of
practice that day.
Taylor said for the
rest of that week Mario
couldn't put the Bible down.
He couldn't get enough.
He was asking questions.
He was just constantly
reading every spare moment
he had, every bus ride, every
few minutes between meetings.
Mario couldn't put
the Bible down.
Taylor said just a few days
before the game, he and Mario
had a conversation where
Mario had started walking
with God in a brand new way.
Sort of walking towards God,
and just the final few days
before the game.
So then Taylor
gets the same phone
call I did just a few days
later, that his teammate,
his friend had died.
And in that moment he was
obviously overcome with grief,
but he was also overcome with
the power and the love of God,
that God would reach Mario
in his final few days
through this random Bible.
And there in that moment Taylor
saw the power, and the grace,
and the love of God.
And in that spot recommitted
his life to Christ, and said,
God, You're real, You're good.
I'm going to follow You.
And so Taylor's telling me
this story four years later,
and he's like, yeah, my life
hasn't been the same since.
I'm on the verge of
tears at this point,
and I'm like, man,
Taylor, that's
the craziest story
I've ever heard.
And it's even crazier
because I was the one that
put the bibles in the locker.
And I thought I was
a total failure.
Gave each other a big hug.
And this is our God.
This is the way God wants
to work through each
and every one of us.
God does have an amazing
purpose for you no matter
where you're at in life, No
matter what your past looks
like, no matter what failures or
mistakes you think you've made,
God has an incredible
purpose for you.
There's a verse in the
back of the Old Testament,
in the book of Habakkuk.
Chapter one, verse five, and
it says, "Look at the nations
and watch and be utterly amazed.
For I am doing
something in your days
that you would not believe,
even if you were told."
This is how God wants to
work through each one of us.
He wants to do things in our
days that we would not believe,
even if He told
us ahead of time.
That's true for
me in this story.
You can see, obviously, that
if God would have told me
ahead of time that I would
try out for the team,
I would make it, I
would overcome injury.
I would get back and
try to find my purpose.
Everything would look like a
failure, a teammate would die.
Then four years later,
1,000 miles away,
I'd reconnect with a
teammate and find out
that God's purposes were at
work, that God was at work,
that God did have
a purpose for me.
If you would've told me
all of this ahead of time,
I wouldn't believed Him.
Even sharing this story
today with you guys,
you probably are like, wow,
this is unbelievable this story.
I have to remind myself every
day that this is how good,
how great our God
is, that He truly
does want to do things
in all of our days
that we would not believe
even if we were told.
This is a story, I
think, about purpose,
but it's also a
story about nudges.
I felt those nudges along the
way to start a Bible study,
to start prayer
group, to be a light,
to put bibles in my
teammates locker.
Mario, that morning,
felt a nudge
to pick up a Bible for the
first time in his life,
and thumb through it
and ask, what is this?
Taylor felt a nudge as
he's pushing the door
to go out to the field
to set down his pads,
turn around, and walk back
towards this incredible purpose
that was laid out for him.
And maybe you're feeling
a nudge right now.
Wherever you're at in your
faith journey, wherever you're
at in life, I have a
feeling that you're
feeling a nudge right now.
That God is knocking on the
door of your heart, to say,
I love you.
I'm delighted in you.
I have amazing purpose for you.
And so look at the
nations and watch.
Be utterly amazed.
For God is doing
something in your days
that you would not believe
even if you were told.
Listen to those nudges, and
just take the next step,
because God is doing
something in your days
that you would not believe,
even if you were told.
Thank you all so much.
God bless you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Yeah, that's really,
really powerful.
Thanks for coming, Ben.
What do you see the
Lord doing through you,
where you are today?
You're still next to Pete
and all these guys who
are so far in their career.
And how do you see him
nudging you and using you
where you are today?
BEN MALCOLMSON: Yeah,
that's a great question.
And I think what
this story has taught
me all along is
that we often don't
see the fruit of our
labor in the moment.
Like that story, it
took me four years later
to see what God was
doing all along.
And so I feel that today.
I still feel discouraged today.
Man, like, do I have a purpose
in the spot that I'm in?
And so I'm just trusting and
knowing and just hopefully
following the nudge every day
that God is placing me there
for a reason.
And I might not see the results.
Just like many of you
in here, maybe you
don't see the results
right now to why
God has you where you're at.
But just to know, and to
trust that God is working.
And so I feel that every day.
I wrestle every day.
Like, do I listen
to discouragement,
or do I listen to
the truth of God
that he does have a purpose?
And maybe someday down
the road, or when we all
get to heaven some
day, we'll get
to see what God was
doing all along.
So thanks for that question.
- So when you're
the butt of a prank,
like I can so see
that happening.
Because from what
little I know, I
know there's a lot of pranking.
And so what do you suggest
is the best mindset going
into a prank?
- To not take yourself
too seriously.
I think a lot of times, we can
take ourselves way too serious.
But that's the great
thing about Coach Carroll
is that he's always keeping
things light and fun.
And I think that's
what it's all about.
So that's a great
question though.
And hopefully, the
prank's not coming to me.
I hope he doesn't tell
me 12 years later that it
was all a joke.
So thank you for that question.
Awesome.
Well, thank you all so much.
I appreciate your time.
And if that story impacted
you, the book just
came out a few months ago,
and it captures that story
plus many other things.
And whether you have a
friend who's into sports,
or a young person
who's searching
for their purpose, or maybe even
a friend or a family member,
I think and I know that
this book will reach them
in a really special way.
So I hope you get a
chance to pick one up.
Thank you.
Thanks, Phil.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]